Now we read a union statement that came out,
the government majority has decided to transform Rai into its megaphone.
He said this through the oversight committee that tested a Standard
that allows AI government representatives to speak in talks without
time constraints and without cross-examination.
Not only 3 news 24 will be able to broadcast in full the political rallies
without any journalistic mediation,
preceded only by an acronym this is not our idea of public service,
where at the Center there is the work of journalists,
journalists who ask questions even uncomfortable,
verify what has been said,
point out in consistencies and for this reason kind viewers inform you that we are
ready to mobilize to ensure you an independent
balanced and pluralistic information.